[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder we
have a
new one division tv spot today it's
short and sweet but
there are actually some very important
things i noticed when you slow this
trailer down and look at it frame by
frame
and i'll break it down and slow it down
so you can see exactly what i'm talking
about in this video but first if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all of the latest mcu news
and so you can enter to win this week's
giveaway which is a modoc
funko pop from the avengers game and big
congratulations to youtube user kieran
tuttle for being last week's winner just
email me in the email in my description
i'll get you your prize
so this tv spot starts off like some of
the other tv spots and trailers have
started off but we do get a new shot of
vision and wanda
riding a tandem bicycle in some sort of
a town
presumably west view the town that they
are currently stuck in since
wanda and vision are most likely stuck
in this town due to wanda or somebody
else creating this bubble reality
now not too much here it's just a really
nice scene of the two of them together
being happy
but this next scene as we go into this
next scene the screen starts to widen
now the screen widens in the original
trailer the second trailer when the
reality kind of starts to come apart and
it becomes obvious that
everything is not what it seems now as
the trailer widens it shows a close-up
of wanda's hand she's performing
magic and then zooms out and shows her
repairing a wall
now originally it looks like she maybe
blasted somebody out or there was some
type of fight but if you slow this scene
down and you freeze frame it you can
actually see
that this room is the room of her
children her children's room is on one
side and she is on the other side which
looks to be like the kitchen or living
room we know it's the children's room
because we can see a toy giraffe and a
rocking chair in there
so now the question is why is there a
hole in the wall and who made the hole
now originally you may think wanda made
the hole maybe she freaked out or sent
somebody through it
but since we know that this is actually
the room of her twin boys perhaps it was
one of the twins themselves
wiccan now if you're not familiar with
wanda's twin boys wiccan and speed
they have different powers from each
other speed has the abilities of his
uncle quicksilver he's very very fast
but wiccan has the abilities of his
mother he's a mutant but he also knows
magic
so this hole in the wall could have been
caused by wiccan
not necessarily wanda because remember
the reality is going to fall apart
and her kids are most likely going to be
a part of that reality falling apart
in which case we could see a child
wiccan not
in control of his powers causing some
chaos of his own in what seems to be
clear in this tv spot
this is what is most likely happening
wikin is the one responsible for the
hole in the wall because wanda wouldn't
put a hole in the wall
or use any type of chaos magic on a wall
that was connected to her children's
room
she wouldn't put them in danger however
a baby wiccan who has no idea how to
control his magic
is most likely responsible and then
again since her twin boys could actually
be
parts of the soul of mephisto just like
they are in the comics
that could add even more chaos to this
mix
but then we have another scene where
wanda appears to be in public
everybody around her is looking at her
and she seems to be freaking out
almost like she's having a panic attack
now one of two things are happening here
one is that her reality is slowly
falling apart and she is
realizing that everything is fake she's
realizing that
she herself created this fake reality or
somebody else created it and put her
inside of it
and it could almost be like the movie
inception when you're inside of a dream
and you change too much
the people in the dream turn on you and
they attack you there could be something
similar happening here
wanda is starting to realize that the
reality around her isn't real and the
reality
turns on her or the second thing that
could be happening here is that she
actually managed to somehow break
out of the reality that she was trapped
in and now she's in public
and back to the real reality and
everybody's looking at her perhaps she
appeared out of nowhere
but if i had to bet i would say the
first option is more likely what is
happening she's realizing the reality
isn't real and whoever created it
is turning on her possibly mephisto or
it could be agatha harkness who could
also be working for mephisto
but the great news is we have less than
a month until we actually find out so
let me know what you think about this tv
spot in the comments down below and if
wanda is trapped in a reality who do you
think
is responsible for trapping her inside
of it let me know what you think don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
bye